[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami
avez vous été sage
et à quoi tu as muse du nounours
ou pardon
excusez moi patron je m'exerce à imiter
un perroquet je vais faire une de ses
blagues à cornichons ya pépites à eau
pour le cheval le hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop aux
tic en nichant tu crois que maintenant
ça encore écrire au j'espère bien que
non si vous voulez qu'il vous raconte
une histoire ils font bien qu'il finisse
de l'écrire quant
à pékin c'est moi
tiens ça c'est curieux
qu'en penses-tu de ce perroquet
cornichons je pense que j'ai encore
jamais vu depuis qu'elle a condamn dada
c'est peut-être un peu rock a perdu ne
m'ont pas vu trop mieux qu'en pro est
afférente est
quand qu à faire mal alliot marie
lyon aussi j'ai peur rios mes amis c'est
quelqu'un qui nous fait face
ne bougez pas
[Musique]
vous allez le voir ce terrible lyon
[Applaudissements]
il ya un grandiose
feu doux je suis tout ouïe et on voit là
des manières d'arroser ainsi les jo je
suis trompé je sens que je vais prendre
froid aux mains la
seiche toit et un gros lyon
[Musique]
vous avez vu moi je ne suis pas les y
être happé à nyon à la campagne
alors petit rôle c'est comme ça que vous
recevez vos habits et toi non
c'est comme ça qui fait peur aux enfants
ces fins skipper vous n'êtes guère
sérieux amis vous feriez mieux décrire
votre livre vous avez resteront dada
demain je me remets au travail
mais à présent ou lui
au revoir on est champion foyer nuit mon
petit cornichons fais de beaux rêves
bonne nuisent data
mes hommages camarades ou
[Musique]
alors gros lyon je ne suis pas l'eau pas
trop je suis à l'ours mais mais depuis
tout mouillé ce n'est rien un peu de
rose et potter
on s'en va pas trop oui en route mon
nounours bonne nuit les petits embrasser
bien fort vos parents
vite vous coucher n'oubliez pas de faire
votre toilette et de bien vous brosser
les dents
et fado bourrin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
le monde